investigators say paul jones concocted a
story about his son aaron's death this
is an interview from jail with 8 news
now in 2017 after the 13 year old's
remains were found
a jury trial was set to begin this week
but instead the attorney for jones filed
this emergency motion for an independent
determination of his competency to stand
trial referring to mental disabilities
along with psychological emotional and
physical trauma throughout his life
according to this 50-page document a
psychologist who evaluated jones
determined he has a severely low iq and
the educational ability of an eight or
nine-year-old he also points to
challenges he faced growing up as a
student with special needs and due to
family neglect and to bullying he faced
according to an arrest report jones
neglected and bullied his son making him
stand against a wall with his arms up
while his siblings were encouraged to
hit him with anything they chose
jones is now charged with murder child
abuse and theft
prosecutors are seeking the death
penalty
on monday clark county district court
judge tierra jones postponed the trial
while jones will be further evaluated
it's hard to believe my son is dead
djanae thomas is erin's biological
mother she sat down with the eye team in
2019. it's
not something that
i would ever understand
there are still many questions
surrounding this case paul jones was on
probation for child abuse when aaron was
placed with him they were also living in
a one-bedroom unit at the seagull suites
with the wife of jones and 11 other
children and aaron jones was missing for
at least four months before he was
reported missing it is clear there were
multiple failures here we expected to
learn more at that trial but it's now
postponed the next court date for jones
is set for january 28th